lurton merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
décidément nous sommes en droit de vous
demander ce qu'il restera demain d'une
loi qui ne se situe plus de nouvelles
libertés ni de nouvelles protections
pour les entreprises et les actifs à
peine avions-nous terminé en commission
des affaires sociales l'examen d'un
texte totalement vidée de mesures
efficaces pour lutter contre le chômage
vous nous annonciez votre volonté
d'augmenter le taux de taxation des
contrats à durée déterminée tout ce
qu'il faut fait tout le contraire de ce
qu'il faut faire pour relancer l'emploi
alors que les demandeurs d'emploi
restent les grands oubliés de vos
propositions
vous ne fait que rajouter les obstacles
entreprises et notamment aux petites
entreprises qui pourtant était selon
vous les premières concernées par la loi
elles comrie vous tromper les demandeurs
d'emplois notamment les jeunes en leur
laissant espérer que cette mesure
obligera les entreprises à créer plus de
cdi
jamais vous ne comprendrez un employeur
embauchés en cdi en rendant plus
difficile l'accès aux cdd au contraire
et vous le savez il renoncera à
embaucher ou aura recours à l'intérim et
il sera de fait contraint de faire peser
sur ses employés des obligations
salariales pour compenser cette nouvelle
taxe monsieur le premier ministre vous
n'avez plus de câble vous naviguez à vue
et ne savait plus comment faire face à
la contestation
cette incohérence existe au sein même de
votre majorité parlementaire qui
expriment de nombreux points de vue
discordants cette incohérence existe
aussi au sein de votre gouvernement et
nous serions en droit de vous demander
ce qu'en pense votre ministre de
l'économie alors monsieur le premier
ministre ma question est simple allez
vous oui ou non commettre cette erreur
de taxer les contrats à durée déterminée
merci la parole est à madame myriam el
khomri ministre du travail de l'emploi
et de la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député gilles lurton
s'il vous plaît vous qui avez suivi les
débats en commission des affaires
sociales moi je tiens ici à remercier le
rapporteur christophe sirugue la
présidente de commission et l'ensemble
des parlementaires des députés qui sont
engagés dans cette démarche d'exclusive
vous ne pouvez pas dire aujourd'hui que
cette loi a été vidé de son contenu
vous ne pouvez absolument pas le dire
parce que la philosophie de cette loi
notamment laissé plus de place à la
négociation collective au sein des
entreprises pour pouvoir mieux s'adapter
cette philosophie est intacte que le
texte projet loi en sortant de la
commission affaires sociales a permis de
renforcer l'appui en direction des tpe
en créant par exemple la provision
surchage en développant les accords type
de branche pour les tpe qui n'ont pas
aujourd'hui cette possibilité de
souplesse en permettant également de
préciser selon l entreprise s'agissant
du motif de licenciement économique
comment pouvez vous dire aujourd'hui que
cette loi était vidéos sont continus
canton permet de créer un cadre contrats
saisonniers
quand on permet de mieux lutter contre
le travail des tâches et quand on permet
également de mettre en oeuvre le compte
personnel d'activités notamment la
formation en direction de ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin
vous m'interrogez sur la question de la
modulation des cdt
je vais vous répondre très précisément
parce que c'est un sujet essentiel
vous le savez la nuit de 2013 c'était à
la demande des organisations patronales
qui ont demandé qu'ils puissent avoir
une modulation des cotisations
patronales à l'assurance chômage en 2013
par la suite le parlement attendu a
entendu cette demande puisque cela a été
intégrée dans la loi de sécurisation de
l'emploi du 2 juin 2013 et elle par la
suite ça a été mis en oeuvre dans le
cadre de la convention assurance chômage
clairement aujourd'hui notre pays est le
deuxième pays utilisateurs des cdd de
moins d'un mois
aujourd'hui nous souhaitons apporter une
réponse à cette hyper précarité notre
but aura toujours besoin de l'aîné et à
monsieur